okay so word has reached my ears that
the ongoing theory about the multiversal
war in loki is actually the events of
secret wars in 2015. do i wish this was
the case
yes because secret wars 2015 and the
events that led up to it and avengers
and new avengers is like one of the
greatest comic book stories
ever told right it's ridiculously good
it's written by jonathan hickman it's
amazing all right so
you know what let's have some fun buckle
your seat belts chaps
this is going to be a wild ride so the
whole thing behind this is that it all
starts with black panther in reality the
whole thing that's basically secret wars
and like avengers new avengers is all
just one giant black panther story but
the way this plays out is that you end
up having this scenario where like
people appear out of nowhere in wakanda
and actually end up killing some of the
wakandans which drives black panther
insane
you guys know he all cares about his
wakandan people and so he ends up
defeating a handful of them and then he
passes through this dimensional barrier
and he sees like a red sky and another
earth and so he ends up capturing what
is basically the leader of this group a
woman by the name of black swan and then
after that he reforms the illuminati so
he brings together
reed richards and neymar the submariner
and captain america
and tony stark iron man and black bolt
of the inhumans the entire group is
basically recalled together and so what
ends up happening here is they
interrogate black swan and they come to
the realization
that's what's happening is actually
called an incursion that's somewhere
along the line an event was set in
motion
by a guy named rabu malal that basically
leads to earth crashing into each other
the way this works is that when an
incursion starts
you have eight hours until it finishes
when the incursion ends
only one of two things can happen either
both earth crash into each other and
they
wipe out both of their universes or one
of the earths is destroyed
and the universes pass through each
other and nothing happens and so one of
the things the illuminati do because
they don't really want to destroy worlds
they grab the infinity gauntlet they get
all the infinity stones and bring them
together because each one of them held
an infinity stone to make sure that they
stayed in safe hands
and so what ends up happening is captain
america gets the infinity gauntlet for
the first time in marvel comics he
pushes the whole universe away and in
the process
all the infinity stones are destroyed
except for the time stone which
vanishes and so following that the
illuminati are screwed the only
conclusion they can come to
in terms of being able to at the very
least keep their earth and their
universe alive while trying to find a
way to stop the incursions is to destroy
incursive worlds
captain america is having none of it
he's like nope we're not wiping out
whole worlds
we're the illuminati we're the most
capable people in the world there's
something we have to do to stop this and
so tony stark directs doctor strange to
wipe the mind of captain america
and they throw him out so captain
america doesn't remember he was ever
part of the illuminati and so following
that the illuminati kind of do two
things
the first is they build a bridge to be
able to look into alternate realities
and see if there are any other universes
out there where people found a way to
stop the incursions from happening and
then two
they start destroying other worlds now
during this time while this is all going
on
thanos basically shows up because he's
essentially looking for his son
across the entirety of the universe
because there's like some kind of
prophecy that like your son will destroy
him or something like that that's where
you're introduced to the coal obsidian
so like the ebony maw
corvus glaive proxima midnight super
giant black dwarf all those characters
and so what ends up happening is they
show up on earth
great big huge series of events pop off
one of the greatest battles of all time
like
there's literally this point there's
this ridiculously amazing point where
like thanos is looking for sunlight
he finds black bolt and like goes to
attack black bolt of the inhumans right
and he's like where's my son at and
black bolt like doesn't tell him
anything
black bolt has a quality sonic screams
so whenever he talks it basically emits
a huge amount of energy
and it's enough to destroy a planet he
shouts at thanos and like nothing
happens
so thanos is like fine keep your secrets
carry them with you to the grass and
like
smashes his head in the ground and this
is the coolest thing ever right so
anyway so thanos
is ultimately defeated and he's locked
away in fact he's defeated by his own
son fame
and so this basically leads to thanos in
the entirety of the of the call obsidian
just kind of being held in stasis now
eventually they're freed
by a combination of things like maximus
the mad and so on and so forth and so
ultimately name with the submariner
allies himself with thanos and the call
obsidian because
at that point in time the illuminati
just didn't want to destroy worlds
anymore
and namor believed they didn't have what
it took in order to actually pull this
off and so when he grabs
thanos and kind of tells him everything
that's going on thanos in the entirety
of the the coal obsidian the whole thing
is they basically start going from world
to world and wiping out entire earth the
difference is that with the illuminati
we're detonating these bombs and
destroying the whole world in one fell
swoop
thanos and those guys were just culling
the world taking their time and like
satiating and all this bloodlust
and then they would destroy the world
and so after that name was just like no
these guys are too extreme for me
so neymar goes to see doctor doom so the
funny thing about this is that dr doom
has this like amazing monologue right
it's like this amazing moment where he's
talking to neymar they start talking
about the nature of like the people in
latvia and dr dooms like do you really
believe that if these people didn't want
to destroy me that they wouldn't
the the whole idea is i keep them fed i
keep them protected so before they pray
to whatever god they pray to you before
they go to sleep they give thanks to me
but ultimately doctor doom turns down
namor's offer to help him find a way to
stop the incursions
because ultimately doctor doom is like
i'm nobody's second choice right he's
like nobody's gonna come and pick me
second now during this time while all
this is happening and like they've freed
black swan the illuminati are working
directly with her to better understand
the incursions and all that kind of
stuff there's one incursion that takes
place
where it involves a blue sky which is a
huge thing because normally the
incursions are red skies the blue skies
mean
map makers and these guys are kind of
wild so the way this plays out is the
map makers are basically individuals
whereby they'll send forward a group
called the sedera madrid's and the whole
point behind them
is they will basically go to a world and
they will conquer and
sanitize the entire world and then what
they'll do is they'll ride that world to
the next incursion point
so that when that world meets another
earth they'll jump from that earth
onto the new earth and they'll repeat
the process over and over again but what
they do is they basically
dislodge a chunk of that world by
literally detonating a bomb
and it just shoots a chunk of that world
out there but it sends out a signal to
the map makers and the map makers follow
their their sedera madris
and then show up on that world and
they're the ones who cleanse everything
right so
they're obviously not to be messed with
while that's going on you've got a third
group which referred to as the black
priest
and they're basically seeming to do the
same thing that the map makers are and
then there's this kind of like unknown
entity out there that's referred to as
the ivory kings right so things kind of
pop off
stuff gets really really crazy the
important thing to understand here is
that you end up getting this time skip
called eight months later
and this is basically when everybody
learns the incursions are happening
captain america is the director of
shield he's like hunting down the
illuminati and trying to capture them
and bring them in
you've got uh the multiversal avengers
team which is basically a whole bunch of
avengers that are going into the
multiverse
try to find a way to stop the incursions
and then you've still got the illuminati
who are basically fugitives evading the
law and then trying to find a way to
stop the incursions like
everyone is trying to find a way to stop
them so anyway what you end up having
here is like all these different
superhero teams going into like these
different facets
and trying to understand what's going on
doctor strange has disappeared a long
time ago like he vanished a while ago so
what ends up happening is the
multiversal avengers
meets up with doctor strange and doctor
strange is basically this guy
who has allied himself with the black
priests and the way this works is that
like if you get a cold your body
responds with the immune system that's
what the black priests are the black
priests are the multiverse just
manifesting these beings
that are supposed to kind of end the
incursions by destroying enough worlds
that the incursion just kind of balances
itself out and so the whole thing behind
this is that doctor strange
learns like all the powers of the black
priest he basically leads them now he
grabs the multiversal avengers and they
basically split up into two groups
one part of the multiversal avengers
goes into the multiverse to try to find
what are called the ivory kings these
kind of mythical beings that people talk
about but they've never actually seen
before
and then some of the other multiversal
avengers ally themselves with doctor
strange and the black priests to find
essentially raboom all and so this is
when things get kind of crazy
because they find the ivory kings man
but they're not the first ones to do it
so you end up learning that at a
previous point in time when the
incursions first kicked off that hank
pym
ant-man had been sent into the
multiverse by reed richards of the
fantastic four in the illuminati to try
to find the cause of the source of the
incursions so he ends up kind of telling
like this crazy journey right like he
kind of appears out of nowhere he just
comes through a portal and he's like i
found him he's like i found the ivory
kings the white lords of wild space
they're the beyonders
and then like like hank pym's like we're
so screwed like there's
nothing we can do to stop these guys and
there isn't because the beyonders are
just stupidly powerful so they're like
okay like tell us what was going on
so hank pam's like okay man so like i go
into the multiverse and the problem is
the multiverse is not really stacked
layers of universes it's just kind of
it's stacked and then sideways there's
no true north so i had to give myself a
kind of compass he's like after that i
started hopping through all these
alternate
realities and so ultimately he comes
across this this point
where like the ivory kings the beyonders
are killing
all the cosmic entities from across the
multiverse right it's just it's
it's cosmic genocide like they're wiping
everybody out and that's why the cosmic
entities
vanished when reid richards and all them
were talking to them because it turned
in like this huge multiversal conflict
so then eventually the living tribunal
pops up right the multiverse given form
this being that's supposed to be like
the supreme power of the multiverse
short of the one above all and then like
the ivory king see him and
three of them wipe out the living
tribunal and that's when like when when
hank pym's like these guys
killed the living embodiment of the
multiverse
what are we gonna do to stop this man
we're a handful of characters here on
earth and we have no real meaningful
powers
that are anywhere near on scale with
these guys
enter doctor doom so what ends up
happening is is doctor strange
and the black priest and then the
handful of the multiversal avengers end
up going
and finding rabumilal only to find out
that it's actually doctor doom
and what had happened is that dr doom
had basically met with a guy named the
molecule man owen reese who'd been
around for an exceedingly long time
and the molecule man revealed his actual
origin and the way this played out is
the beyonders had basically used the
molecule man as an experiment that they
had come across the existence of the
multiverse they were curious about it
and so they created one molecule man in
every single universe
this guy is ridiculously overpowered
imagine if a person could alter the
atomic structure of the multiverse
and that's basically the molecule man
right so the whole thing behind this is
that the the beyonders wanted to
detonate all the molecule men
at one time but doctor doom and the
molecule man of the main marvel universe
kind of beat him to the punch by
accidentally killing one and when that
happened
it obliterated the whole universe what
this did is it created a domino effect
when that universe blew up it took the
universe's next to it and
bumped those into the universes next to
them which bumped into the universes
next to them
and so on and so forth and so literally
universes were just being pushed outward
and like an explosion pattern and that's
what caused the incursions it was all
started by doctor doom and so what they
ended up realizing they had to do
was travel across every single universe
and kill as many molecule men as they
possibly could but killing a god is no
small thing and so in order to pull this
off doctor doom
created the black swans to travel from
universe to universe
just wiping them all out as he possibly
could during this process the beyonders
became aware
that molecule men were being destroyed
across the multiverse so they entered
into the multiverse and then they
started killing all the cosmic entities
trying to find out what was going on
with their experiment and so what ends
up happening here is one of the craziest
things ever right what ends up happening
here
there's some crazy event where like read
richard and the illuminati are like okay
so here's the entire standing of the
multiverse we have like a few hundred
thousand universes left
and then like that they're gone and it's
like a dozen universes like no i'm sorry
it's only two universes left right it's
it's the main novel universe and like
the ultimate universe right and they're
like what happened right i mean just
like
in the blink of an eye they're gone now
the other part of this is that where
doctor doom created the black swans
the beyonders because they couldn't
consistently enter into the universe
they're the ones who made the map makers
and the map makers were doing what they
were doing charting the entirety of the
multiverse
to find out what was causing these
incursions to happen in the first place
and so following that
things get nuts right because what you
have are like a few hundred thousand
universes that are left all
grievances have been put to the side at
this point right it's just everybody
doing what they can to survive
and then oh my god and then thor and
hyperion die okay so here's a crazy
thing so thor and hyperion hyperion is
basically a marvel analog of superman
there's this crazy moment where like
them and the rest of the multiversal
avengers
end up facing off against like some of
the beyonders right it's like two
beyonders come out
and one of them is destroyed by the star
brand who's basically a character that
has as much power as he needs to destroy
whoever he's fighting and so ultimately
like
most all of them are killed and it comes
down to thor and hyperion who are the
two guys left right hyperion's eyes have
more or less been gouged out at this
point
and thor's arm's been ripped off right
so like i mean they're ragtag
i mean like you know they're not gonna
make it all these beyonders come
pouring out of this portal and like
hyperion's like we're gonna die here
today
and and thor's like yeah man but if
we're gonna die like then i will see you
in valhalla
and and and like hyperion's like brother
today i will meet you there and like
they go
racing into the beyonders man wow they
go racing into the honors
and then it's just like in the deep cold
blackness of space
there was a crack of thunder something
lightning and then
silence and like that's the end of thor
and hype here it's like the last ride of
the gods of marvel it's one of the
coolest moments ever in the whole story
i was like
oh my god when they died it was amazing
so the crazy thing about this is that
you've got like a few hundred thousand
universes that are left in the
multiverse right
and so the way this plays out is that
you end up having the illuminati in
these guys
who are looking at these hundred
thousand some odd universes and then
suddenly they're down to 12 or down to
two and they're like hold on how do we
lose
all these hundreds of thousands of
universes and we're down to two come to
find out
what had happened is doctor strange dr
doom and the molecule man had gone
around and captured all these molecule
men from across the multiverse and then
challenged the beyonders to appear
and when they did they had like all the
molecule men encased inside this like
giant box and they released them all at
once and detonated them and so like it
destroyed all the beyonders but in the
process
wiped out what was left of the
multiverse so there's like two universes
left the main marvel universe
and the uh the ultimate universe and
like they're incursing on each other and
so basically you get like the final
incursion at the very beginning of the
secret wars event
and that leads to like the the total
obliteration
of the entirety of the multiverse and so
basically like after that you have like
doctor doom who essentially recreates
reality as best you can on battle world
which is like it's a really rough
rough spot right like battle world is
basically the marvel cosmic version of
like the south side of chicago you know
what i mean like
it's rough and so ultimately like doctor
doom is defeated
by reed richards after the molecule man
takes doctor doom's power away
and gives it to reed and then reed
recreates all of existence right like
creates basically resets everything so
it was it was a nut story it was an
amazing story
but having said that if you want to see
the whole thing in its entirety
check out the video in the description
like i covered the whole thing on comics
explain but here's the thing about this
right so so let's talk about how loki
and the multiverse would tie into this
so a lot of people are saying that it
would be secret wars or the events
leading up to secret wars
because of like the whole segment that
we got with the animation and the
multiversal war and all that kind of
stuff i would be fully on board with
this
if feige and them had not come out and
said that the mcu is essentially its own
multiverse now he said it's going to
become
its own multiverse he didn't say that it
is its own multiverse and so
we know that's coming later on down the
line up to this point the events of of
the marvel cinematic universe are
considered or were considered an
alternate reality
in the in the the marvel entertainment
marvel comics landscape
and so there's room here to make the
case that it is actually the events of
secret wars that are being referred to
in this multiverse award the biggest
problem with this is the animation says
that the
time keepers were the ones who restored
the timeline not anybody else like reed
richards
we know that it's not one of these
things where like marvel can't use
reid's name because fox owns it because
disney owns all that stuff now so like
they could use reid's name if they
wanted to and just be like well it was
all fixed by reed richards
but if you look at the timekeepers and
marvel comics they're not altruistic
they don't do things because it's the
right thing to do the timekeepers are
dicks
and so like all they really care about
are themselves like that's that's it
just like
maintaining their power so it's 100
possible that like what you see in that
animation
is complete and total propaganda right i
mean one of the things we know from like
that weird little assistant guy who was
showing
uh loki all the infinity stones in the
desk and seeing people were using them
for paperweights is that he's lived his
whole life there they didn't even know
what a fish was
is it that far out of the realm of
possibility that they believe whatever
the timekeepers tell them
especially because the judge was looking
at them from an almost like
warship type position right like we
believe the time keepers like we don't
really
believe they're wrong or they do
anything incorrect like they almost have
a kind of religious zealotry about them
in terms of how they view the
timekeepers so it's entirely possible
the timekeepers are really just dicks
and they're like okay look like we're
not the ones who fix
everything it was really this guy who
could stretch named reed richards in an
alternate reality who fixed everything
and like that would be it right which
would be a great way to introduce reid
but here's the biggest problem that you
have
even if it really is the events of
secret wars that they're that they're
explaining i mean look at the
explanation
that i gave you and that's a
stripped-down explanation right that's a
basic
explanation you really going to take all
that and condense it down
to what would amount to maybe a 10
possibly 15-minute explanation
in either loki or doctor strange 2 no
that's not going to happen
so either it would be a modified version
of that which is far less eventful and
impactful or you would just kind of have
to
nullify it and just say that's not what
we're referring to if i'm being honest i
think the multiversal war they're
talking about
is something i can to a kind of blend
between the king the conqueror empire
and like the universal church of truth
that's what i think is really going on
the universal church of truth in marvel
comics was actually a church that was
founded by the future evil alter ego
of adam warlock a character by the name
of magus and so technically the church
only exists on a universal level
you don't really see them operating in a
multiversal level but the mcu could
change that easily right i mean
literally
a stroke of a pen fixes that problem so
like
it's one of those things where they
could be doing that and kind of merging
it with kane the conqueror
the reason why i say that is we know
we're going to see kang in in
ant-man and the wasp iii we know that
we're going to see uh immortals or at
least the rumors that we're going to see
immortus
and uh in the loki tv show and immortus
and kang are basically the same thing
imagine like you right now are king the
conqueror and mortis
is you 10 years ago if you didn't have
any of the experiences you've had
over the last 10 years it's still you
just a different version of you
that's really all the differences
between immortus and kane the copper
the important thing is that if we really
do see those kinds of characters
what i think is actually going on in
this multiversal war as it was largely
all probably started by kang
or immortus or whatever version they
choose to make the main version of kane
the conqueror is the bad guy
whatever version they choose he's the
one that started it and much like the
universal church of truth he exists on a
multiversal scale right so basically
king the conqueror rules entire
universes across the multiverse
and if he follows the universal church
of truth philosophy
then he'll basically show up to the
multiverse or at least to a singular
universe
most likely earth or some other
landscape or whatever and basically say
like you know i am cain the conqueror
you should bend the knee to me and let
me be your leader and if they say okay
cool
then he just kind of takes power and
everything's pretty peaceful if they say
no
he just cleanses the place and executes
anybody
who who basically dissented and then he
conquers it anyway so that's what the
universal church of truth did in marvel
comics so i assume it'll be something
akin to that
but i think the multiversal war they're
talking about was likely started by kang
either that or like a mortise or
whatever it's all the same thing i don't
think it's the events of secret wars
it's just too much stuff to cram
into a you know 15 minute explanation in
a tv show or a movie
just way too much to do i would say it'd
be very possible if we got like doctor
strange parts one and two
then i would say okay then that's
probably it because they could dedicate
like half an hour or even like 45
minutes
to kind of explaining all that stuff and
making it all make sense because
they've basically got a five hour movie
to work with split into two parts but
like we're not going to get that like
it's just it's too much to cover too
much to introduce too much going on
at one point in time so let me know what
you guys think down in the comments and
i will catch you all later
peace